- She's an Oscar winning
actress and an insanely
successful businesswoman
with her brand, Goop.
Let's say hello to Gwyneth
Paltrow, everybody!
(upbeat music)
(applause and cheers)
- Hi.
- Hello!
- How are you?
- I'm so good.
Okay, I'm a little bummed
you took your glasses off.
Those were so rock and roll.
You had the black glasses.
It looks so cool.
- Can I leave them on?
I can see you better if I actually
have them on.
- Okay, I'm just saying,
you look cool in them.
I would wear them if I
looked that good in them.
But hey, we just spoke with a
woman who's headed to space.
Would you ever go to space?
- Literally never.
(laughter)
- I don't know that I would either.
I find the thought exhilarating,
but then the actuality, like
it sets in and I'm like, mm.
I don't know if it's 'cause we have kids.
Do you think we would
have thought differently
if we were like 21 and no kids?
- I mean, I'm like afraid
to fly to Cleveland
on a regular plane.
(laughter)
No way.
- So not a flyer.
Well, how about your daughter?
She's 16 now, is she adventurous?
- She's incredibly adventurous.
I mean, it's interesting.
She's like a great mix of
pragmatic and adventurous.
She loves to kind of explore life
outside her comfort zone
but then she's very
logical at the same time.
I think it's a good combo.
- Yeah, it sounds very balanced.
I'm gonna work on that.
16 year old seems to be nailing it.
Speaking of kids, I saw
this photo that you posted,
you said, "Little dude in the back
pretending he didn't eat half my sando."
They don't ever ask!
My kids just walk up and take my stuff.
Does that happen all the time to you?
- Yes.
You know, it's so funny.
I remember actually before I had kids
I have a cousin, first cousin
who I'm really close to,
her name's Lecy and I
remember her telling me,
she's like, "Having kids is
the best thing in the world,
but it's a totally different game."
She's like, "I mean, you make
yourself a whole sandwich,
and then they just take it
and you don't even care,
you just give them the sandwich."
But I've always remembered that.
So, yeah.
I think it's good when kids feel
that level of healthy
entitlement for a parent
and like what you're supposed
to provide for them, you know?
- Yeah.
Well I think a healthy
dose of entitlement,
not too much.
- [Gwyneth] Yeah, true.
- Do your kids like to tease you?
- Oh my God, constantly, constantly.
I mean, we're out of it now,
but I went through a
phase with my daughter
where I wasn't allowed
to like hum, dance, move.
Like I was mortifying her on every level.
She makes fun of me more than my son does.
My son, he's like,
his humor is different,
but she just like, yeah,
she's always making fun of me.
- Oh my, my daughter's already doing it
at the age of six.
It's been great foreshadowing
for what's to come.
But I tweeted you a while back
and I said that you have an honest
and captivating voice and I
asked you to make an album.
So, Gwyneth, how's the album coming along?
- Oh my God.
This was so nice of you, by the way.
- I meant it, by the way!
I think that you are a great singer,
like in different movies,
I've seen you singing.
Do you love singing?
- I do.
I find it really...
I find it hard.
Like I think there's a
vulnerability that comes
out when you sing.
That's like, for me, it's a bit shocking
and I think that's a good thing.
I like being a backup singer more
like I love singing harmonies
and stuff like that.
There's no way I could make
an album or do what you do.
I feel like I've been able
to hide behind characters
who sing and things,
but if it was just me,
it would be way too vulnerable, no way.
- I just liked it.
I appreciate any singer
that it sounds vulnerable
like what you said, and
it sounds believable
but you're an actor.
So I guess when you play
the characters, it's easier,
like you said, to dip into
those feelings or whatever
but that's what I loved about your voice
and in the few things
I've seen you sing in.
So this is hilarious to me.
You were patient zero in "Contagion".
Did you think that
would ever really happen
in our lifetimes?
- Oh my gosh.
Can you believe it?
- No, actually still, no.
- It's just nuts.
You know, it's funny, when
we were making the movie
and we were on the set,
I remember the producer
and writer saying, "No,
this is gonna happen."
I mean, 'cause the writer
had been researching
these kinds of viruses and he's like,
"We're due for one, it's
gonna happen in our lifetime."
And I thought, I can't
even think about that.
That's just way too scary to even fathom.
And I can't believe that
it actually has happened.
I mean, we've all just been through it.
It's been wild.
- I know it's a crazy thing too,
when you have kids to try and explain
what's happening when you
yourself are kind of lost.
But you chose, this actually
I've found interesting as well,
you chose to not take lead
roles in movies anymore.
So what was the reason for that?
'Cause you're awesome, so
it seems kind of a waste
for all of us.
- Aw, you're so nice.
Well, my kids, I mean, I just,
you know, I just couldn't bear getting
on a plane and being away for months
at a time or missing bedtime.
I just really wanted to be home as much
as possible while they're
still in the house.
You know, it's a finite
time and it's hit me so much
my daughter is now a
junior in high school.
It's gone so fast
and in a year and a half,
she'll be in college.
And of course, hopefully
we'll maintain our closeness
in our relationship, but that just,
that her life begins.
And you know what I mean?
It's such a finite time that they're home.
So I wanted to try to focus
more on work that I could do
at home or at an office around the corner
and not so much traveling
or those, you know, big 16,
18 hour days that when
you're shooting something,
you're just out of the
house for that long.
- Yeah, no, it is hard
definitely finding that balance
with work and personal life.
Well, Steven Spielberg is your godfather,
so that's random.
Your life is crazy.
Has he documented any moments of your life
and do they look epic?
(laughter)
- That is so funny.
You know, he is, he always has
a video camera in his hands.
So any family event, 4th
of July, Thanksgiving
whatever the case may
be, he's always videoing.
So yes, he definitely has videoed me
over the years and he was actually
the only person who was videoing
at my wedding two and a half years ago.
So I guess I had a
pretty good videographer.
- You had a great wedding videographer.
(laughter)
That's amazing.
Did he charge you?
That's the best part.
- He knew-
- That's amazing though, you've
been married for two years.
I mean, coming from
someone who's literally
in the midst of divorce,
I can't even imagine doing it again.
So, I mean, that's amazing
that you found love and
you found this space
and the vulnerability, that level
to say yes and do it again.
Was that hard for you?
- Probably the hardest
thing I've ever done
and probably allowing
myself to learn the lessons
that I needed to learn from my divorce
and then being able to
really kind of do that
work on myself and then
open myself up again.
And my husband, he just,
he requires that kind
of presence and intimacy, and
it was really hard for me.
Like I wasn't good at it before.
I still struggle with it, but
you will have it again, Kelly,
it just takes time.
- Well, I'm actually in that
place where I think a lot
of people I've heard
that go through divorce.
It's almost like you start
dating yourself again.
Like you actually make time for you again.
And I love dating me.
So I'm like, I'm actually
not looking for it,
but it's also a beautiful
thing for a lot of people
like me that are going through
divorce that do want that
in the future to let know
that it can, you know,
and will probably happen for you.
But how did you learn co-parenting
with your ex?
Because co-parenting
can be very difficult,
because I think divorce is hard
on people, but it's hardest
on the kids and I'm from
a divorced family too,
twice over as a kid.
So it's harder on the kids.
Was that all right with you?
Is that easier or is it hard to navigate?
- I think we made a commitment
early on to be a family
even though we weren't a couple,
which, you know, sounds
like weird and impossible,
but we worked with a
therapist who was amazing
at helping us communicate.
And we, luckily we both came
from families that were
strong and, you know,
our parents were still together.
My parents were together
until my father passed away.
We really did want the same things.
And we wanted the divorce ideally to
impact the kids as little as possible.
And I had talked to a lot of
people, children of divorce
and I said, you know, what can
I learn from your experience?
And everybody had the same
thing, which was just,
I wanted my parents to be
friends and like each other.
And I didn't want to feel
that terrible feeling
when my dad wouldn't come into the house
or my mom made my dad drop
us at the end of the road.
So we just tried to make a
commitment to really stay close
and we've been able to do that.
It wasn't easy.
I'm proud of us for having
kind of really stuck to it.
And now it's many years.
And so it's much easier now.
It's harder in the beginning
of course, but you just have to
make a concerted effort
to really think about
what is best for the
children in this moment
and then you just have
to kind of push your own
reactivity down as best you can.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, yeah, absolutely.